bonjour arnaud benedetti bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous dans
cette matinale verte et france avant de
rentrer dans le détail un commentaire
peut-être sur cette abstention record
66% des français ne sont pas allés voter
hier ses 2 français sur 3 quelle est
votre analyse sur les raisons de cette
abstention
c'est le principal enseignement de cette
élection c'est un phénomène qui est
massif qui est spectaculaire et comme
vous l'avez rappelé dans votre portage
qui oublient à une tendance de fond ce
depuis maintenant plusieurs années voire
plusieurs décennies il y avait
simplement trois raisons d'abord le fait
aujourd'hui que l'offre politique dans
son ensemble ne correspond aux frais 120
blement pas ou insuffisamment aux
attentes des françaises et des français
une deuxième raison qui est lié aussi au
fait que le système administratif
politique et administratif local est
devenu d'une kelly du têt l'illisibilité
on part du fameux millefeuille
administratif que les électrices et les
électeurs ont du mal à se retrouver dans
ce maquis de compétences enchevêtrés que
constitue d'un côté les régions les
départements les communes les
intercommunalités
troisième raison on ne peut pas non plus
totalement sous estimé que l'essai de
sortie de crise sanitaire
et puis quand même là aussi renforcer
l'abstention mais la tendance de fond
c'est que aujourd'hui il y à une sorte
de démocratie du vide qui s'impose en
france c'est à dire d'une démocratie
sans électricité sans électeurs ou en
tout cas avec des électrices et des
électeurs très simplement mobilisés vous
parlez de l'offre politique on a entendu
et sections dans ce reportage une dame
dire qu elle allait voter blanc est-ce
qu'il faut prendre en compte désormais
ce vote blanc selon vous vous savez
c'est un serpent de mer alors bien
évidemment le vote blanc ça signifie
quoi ça signifie que vous adhérez aux
rites démocratique mais que en votant
blanc vous ne voulez pas cautionner
justement le spectre de l'offre
politique parce qu'il ne vous convient
pas mais la réalité c'est que la
politique c'est aussi non seulement bien
évidemment la possibilité de contester
mais c'est aussi la possibilité
d'apporter des solutions
d'adhérer à un projet de produits vision
de la société dont je le vote blanc
n'est j'allais dire qu'un pis-aller qui
ne règle pas les problèmes de fond du
fonctionnement institutionnel
démocratique et politique de la vie
publique alors une défaite cuisante on
la vit pour la république en marche qui
enterre ses velléités d'ancrage local
carrément illuminés dans les hauts de
france on va le voir on va d'abord voir
ces cinq ministres qui avaient été
envoyés pour battre le candidat
les républicains et xavier bertrand vous
les voyez à l'antenne ils sont donc hors
course
aujourd'hui est ce qu est ce que cela
traduit selon vous le fait que cinq
ténors de l'exécutif soit out ce matin
enfin c'est un vrai strike électorale si
je puis dire parce que c'est sans
précédent et c'est quand même d'une
certaine manière une humiliation pour la
majorité et surtout la stratégie du
président de la république s'il voulait
en fait il ya quand même les propriétés
qui à mon sens extrêmement importante
dans le maquereau nisme c'est que le
maquereau nisme depuis finalement le
début de son aventure et depuis son
accession à l'elysée visa dépolitiser en
décrivant la société française
aujourd'hui il est la victime de cette
stratégie
ensuite bien évidemment on a vu que
durant toute cette campagne électorale
qui a d'ailleurs peut susciter d'intérêt
parmi les françaises et des français
comme en témoigne le niveau d'abstention
l'exécutif s'est efforcé d'avoir une
stratégie à géométrie variable selon les
régions et dont le but était
manifestement à la fois de se faufiler
dans un trou de souris lorsque c'était
possible sur le terrain ou soit tout
simplement de rendre illisible le
résultat de ces élections la réalité
c'est qu'il ya une très grande
visibilité
aujourd'hui des suites à ce premier tour
la première en effet ça a été dit c'est
l'abstention la deuxième c'est le recul
très net du rassemblement national
il faudra s'interroger d'un évidemment
sur les raisons de ce recul
et troisièmement bien évidemment c'est
la défaite cuisante sur le plan
territorial d'un parti majoritaire
n'a pas été capable en quatre ans de
pouvoir se marier territorialement c'est
la première fois sous la vème république
une formation politique est une
formation majoritaire au plan national
ne dispose quasiment d'aucun relais
locaux ce qui t'amène ne manquera pas de
poser problème à l'avenir
vous parliez de la baisse du
rassemblement national une abstention
surtout chez les électeurs du
rassemblement national a priori cette
partisans sur dix du et rennes se sont
abstenus d'ailleurs on a entendu hier
les ténors du parti qui ont vivement
appelé à la mobilisation pour le second
tour est ce que c'est une des raisons
selon vous est-ce que cet appel peut
être entendu il faut qu'ils
s'interrogent sur leur stratégie
également c'est à dire que si vous
voulez il est clair que ce qui s'est
passé au niveau des élections régionales
et départementales s'était déjà passé
lors des élections municipales pendant
très longtemps on a considéré dans
l'histoire électorale récente que
l'abstention était un phénomène qui
bénéficie au front national ça a été
vrai au front national d'ions première
période
ce n'est plus aujourd'hui clairement
lorsque les classes populaires et des
classes moyennes ne se mobilise pas la
première offre politique à pâtir de
cette démobilisation on l'a vu lors des
élections municipales
on avait vu aussi dans une moindre
mesure lors des dernières élections
européennes c'est le rassemblement
national qui en pâtit ça c'est une
réalité sauf que la réalité c'est que le
rassemblement national n'est pas
propriétaire du réservoir sociologique
potentiels qu'ils pourraient voter pour
lui et cette élection vient le démontrer
si il faut que le rassemblement national
peut-être s'interroge aussi sur sa
stratégie finalement ne sommes nous pas
aujourd'hui confronté aux limites de la
stratégie de dédiabolisation de
banalisation de l'offre du rassemblement
national
on voit que déjà mais devront chez un
certain nombre de voix l'intérieur du
parti s'interrogeait sur cette stratégie
quand on n'arrive pas à mobiliser
l'électorat on ne peut pas considérer
que parce que l'abstention est
structurel que c'est cette abstention
structurelles qui explique la défaite il
ya aussi un élément stratégique l'autre
qui doit être pris en compte dans
l'analyse que de vraies
les cadres du rassemblement national
dans ce gros flux importants important
par rapport à 2015 autres régions
particulièrement inscrits et pour ce
second tour évidemment la région paca où
le fn arrive en tête le rn 2 thierry
mariani avec 4 points d'avance sur
renaud muselier une région qui est qui
pourrait être remportée selon vous par
le rn il reste il reste une possibilité
au corps pour le rn de l'emporter tout
va dépendre de l'attitude de monsieur
fait lydia qui apparemment a annoncé mme
attias dre sa liste ça c'est un premier
élément est bien évidemment tout va
dépendre pour le rassemblement national
du comportement des abstentionnistes un
sursaut de mobilisation pourrait
peut-être il faut être très prudent
hypothétiquement profiter à thierry
mariani et permettre un gain d'une
région qui en l'occurrence permettrait
d'effacer les mauvais résultats du
premier tour mais c'est quand même une
situation qui est compliqué parce que la
dynamique de résistance de monsieur
muselier peut être aussi l'élément de
mobilisation en partie pour son
électorat
même si sur la liste de renaud muselier
c'est la seule d'ailleurs il y à des
personnes de la république en marche
seule façon pour eux d'ailleurs d'avoir
des élus la république en marche pour ce
scrutin
on peut se poser on peut se poser la
question malgré la bonne résilience
électorale de monsieur vous liez de
l'intérêt tactique de cette stratégie
qu'est ce qui aurait été le résultat de
monsieur muselier s'il n'avait pas louer
cette alliance implicite avec eux la
république en marche
on peut penser que son résultat utt au
moins similaire voire meilleur je ne
suis pas sûr qu'en tout cas le résultat
d'hier soir contrairement à ce que j'ai
entendu valide la stratégie de monsieur
muselier la liste si la liste de gauche
ce maintien est ce que ce serait la fin
du front républicain il est clair que le
front républicain
et les morts depuis longtemps c'est à
dire que on essaye de le réactiver
à chaque élection mais on voit que les
digues que constitue cet objet politique
très singulier que constitue le le front
républicain se sont depuis amplement
infléchie on l'avait déjà vérifié lors
d'autres scrutins
clairement aujourd'hui le front
républicain n'est plus en mesure
véritablement de se reconstituer
telle qu'on l'a connue par exemple dans
les années 2001 2002 lorsque jean-marie
le pen lui présidé le front national ce
qui était le front national à libourne
arnaud benedetti il nous reste six
minutes pour parler de l'île de france
qui va être scrutée également pour ce
second tour valérie pécresse qui arrive
en tête avec 36% des voix
sauf que les listes de gauche vont
fusionner derrière le candidat écolo
julien bayou est ce que ça peut
renverser la vapeur
ça sera compliqué parce que si vous
voulez l'arithmétique qui à paris
facialement électorale ne fait pas mal
chimie du résultat donc valérie pécresse
arrive très largement en tête donc il ya
un écart et une dynamique qui est en sa
faveur et on sait très bien que l'écart
et la dynamique du premier tour est un
élément tout à fait essentiel pour le
second tour même si on le voit
facialement la gauche si elle s'unit
peut quasiment faire jeu égal avec
valérie pécresse alors dernier mot tout
de même sur les élections en france
puisqu'on le sait emmanuel macron avait
même fait une visite enfin lors de sa
tournée pour prendre le pouls des
français emmanuel macron va devoir
mettre un bulletin pour xavier bertrand
ont finalement alors qu'il a tenté tout
fait de tout faire pour le pourra
justement le battre est clairement en
tout cas la stratégie qui consistait à
déstabiliser non personne n'était duc le
président sortant des lots de france a
échoué elle échoué de façon magistrale
cinq ministres ont tapie qui ne passent
pas la barre des 10%
je ne vois pas aujourd'hui contenu
du discours d' emmanuel macron et de la
macro ni de désigner comme ennemi
principal le rassemblement national
d'autre solution que pour monsieur
macron est en tout cas sa formation
politique d'appeler ça a été déjà ça a
été déjà c'est à soutenir monsieur
bertrand au second tour même si
manifestement monsieur bertrand n'a pas
besoin en l'occurrence de ce soutien
pour s'assurer une élection au
relativement confortable
ça pourrait remettre en cause une
éventuelle candidature de d'emmanuel
macron vu le piètre aux cordes de la
république en marche très compliqué en
tout cas sa charge des représentations
et les interprétations que l'on fait de
la scène politique
l'un des sujets majeurs pour des manuels
vacances c'est de s'imposer qu'on veut
l'un des meilleurs remparts or le virant
par sa marine le pen aujourd'hui bon
lorsqu'on regarde et il faut les
regarder aujourd'hui encore plus avec
précaution qu' il y à 48 heures
les hypothèses présidentielle on voit
que manifestement il n'a plus cette
capacité de résistance par rapport à
l'offre le pénis qui était la sienne
entre en 2010 elle donc il peut se
créent en effet un effet d'éviction vers
un autre candidat de droite tout de
centre-droit donc on peut considérer que
ces élections régionales en tout cas en
tout cas ce premier tour des élections
régionales à savoir ce que ça donnera
lors du second tour change un peu là la
lecture que l'on peut faire de la scène
politique française
merci beaucoup arnaud un béné des pieds
pour cette analyse ce matin au lendemain
de ces élections régionales et
départementales en france